this is how it used to work a real
estate agent would lock in the client
they'd stage the place hold an open
house every single weekend
and hope that the right buyer walks
through that door
ten years ago you could probably go look
at a house
and circle back two to three weeks later
and still have an opportunity to make a
bid
the first time i received a lead through
instagram my mind was blown
if you're seeing something in a
neighborhood that is established
you have two to three days after the
open house in this market to make an
offer
our world has shifted so much folks are
getting comfortable doing
business either through social media or
100 virtual
social media like everything else it
touches has turned the real estate
business upside down
[Music]
you've heard this trope before
millennials aren't buying and owning as
much as their parents generation
be it a car a diamond or a home but the
lack of ownership
is not always by choice in 2018 a survey
found that 89 percent of millennial
americans
want to buy a home they just can't
afford it as of 2019
millennials of all stripes owned only 5
of us housing
compared with 15 for gen xers
millennials haven't been able to make
these big ticket purchases the same way
as
their predecessors did now this is down
to the financial crisis we have
rising student loan debt and a higher
cost of living
now millennials are getting older
they're earning more money
and saving more so now is about the time
where a lot of them are going out and
making those purchases
and now having been stuck at home for
over a year the same generation that
embraced ubers and airbnbs
wants something to call their own i got
married and i have a child so
you know looking for more space and
thought about the conventional route of
young and single and live in the city
and then move out to the suburbs when
you have a kid and a wife i've seen a
whole bunch of my friends just move on
down to the west palm beach miami area
austin texas so they are certainly
moving out of the city but space was top
of mind for them moving out
we lived in williamsburg for about 16
plus years
and week two in the pandemic we just
realized
we needed more so we started looking for
a house right away
we now live in goshen new york which is
about an hour and a half from new york
city
instagram accounts like circa houses and
cheap old houses
offer a glimpse into the perfect
suburban life often at a price point not
too dissimilar to what adults pay for
rent in major cities
by the end of 2020 new yorkers who
didn't flee paid an
average of 2700 a month for an apartment
even as rent prices plummeted during the
pandemic
millennials make a large percentage of
spending right now and that makes them a
valuable consumer for brands that means
they're being courted by
everyone out there to spend with them
they grew up online
they're comfortable with pretty much
anything that you can do there and
that's that's
buying things selling things craigslist
ebay all that
making a hundred dollar purchase on
craigslist or a thousand dollar purchase
on ebay it's not that much of a leap to
go
even further if you're buying a fancy
piece of jewelry or a house for a
million bucks
the uptick in home demand fueled by the
pandemic combined with record low
interest rates
has made home buying extremely
competitive over the last year
so much so that some millennials look to
social media to shop and actually
buy their first house site unseen
i saw sort of something on my instagram
feed
and you know clicked and we ended up
seeing this house the houses weren't
really being shown at that time because
we were in full lockdown
we became really interested one youtube
video
20 zlo photos that is it
the red hot housing market spells
opportunities for developers targeting
this demographic
getting eyeballs strictly through social
media
people are not looking in the the back
section of the times anymore
for real estate listings our demographic
is between late 20s to
mid 40s and that demographic is spending
a lot of time
on social media and they're doing a lot
of shopping via
instagram and other social media
platforms
this is joshua galb in pele hamburger
during the pandemic
the two new york city-based developers
started neville house
a new construction project two hours
north of the city
unlike most traditional real estate
listings the pair bypassed the use of a
broker
and advertise their homes directly on
instagram no fees
no commissions you used to have to hire
a broker work with them they would do
showings on site now you basically put
your renderings on
on instagram and within an hour you have
15 20
replies saying can i come see it
directly with you and
let's see it tomorrow and it's just
completely changed the game
most people have that image in their
head of the quintessential
upstate modern cabin set in the woods
we've definitely tried to tap into that
and
create something that's attainable for
these people say you can have that
you can be swiping through instagram and
that can be your home too
there's been quite a proliferation of
these direct to consumer brands
there's just tons of them out there it's
not that hard to start up a website
that's that sells things and get things
manufactured
uh for that e-commerce platform so like
all birds with shoes
casper with mattresses or warby parker
with glasses
all of that means a lot more opportunity
for brands in the online shopping space
so it's natural that real estate would
want to get involved as well with these
big ticket items
10 years ago the broker would drive the
search
now i think that my clients texts me
listings they have
alerts they find things quicker than we
do sometimes because we're out and about
i'd say that the buyer is much more
involved these days
social selling is creating brand new
ways to shop so let's look at
vintage clothing for example there are
sellers on instagram finding successful
ways to sell
one-of-a-kind items it's that fleeting
nature the ephemeral nature of
social media you post the item online
and
whoever's first gets that one-of-a-kind
item now
real estate has similar scarcity to it
there's
one place to buy it's one home one
apartment
one one thing it's one of a kind
but the rise in social media real estate
isn't just about the instant
gratification
researcher andre perry who studies
economic inclusion at the brookings
institute
says social media has evolved from the
days of online hangout spaces and mood
boards
to a powerful change agent social media
is a primary source to get news and
information
but it's not just about social media
it's about the movement that we're in
the
racial justice uprising really gave
people a sense of
worth and empowerment and so people not
only are getting information about
what protects people in the long run
from economic shocks things like wealth
in his research andre found that not
only are more millennials buying homes
during the pandemic
the rate of home ownership among black
millennials are at historic highs
the fastest way to accumulate wealth in
this country traditionally has been
through home ownership millennials in
particular are saying hey
i want protection i want to live longer
i want
my education to go further let me
acquire wealth and and the fastest way
to do that
is through home ownership
when the pandemic hit many of the
amenities or the comforts that came
along
with those living conditions were gone
folks
couldn't go to bars and fancy shops
and so you saw instead of people going
out
buying clothes they saved their money
and bought property
and outside of the city generally people
are moving
to the suburbs to rural areas places
where
home prices are a little bit cheaper
many home buyers are looking for houses
outside the major metropolitan areas
additionally many home buyers are
looking for direct outdoor access and
added space as the uncertainty about the
virus persists
millennials are also looking to
influencers not just for the latest
trends and tick tock dances
but to partake in important
conversations be it about politics or
personal
finance or anything in between real
estate ownership
let's start small let's don't be scared
to start small
instead instead of renting a big house
in the hills
in california like most artists do buy
you one that's on the flat
i meet folks like brandon rule and
charlemagne the god
you have residential real estate and you
have commercial real estate they're
talking about
buying homes when i was coming up really
home buying was a mysterious
shrouded process that only a few people
could teach me now i can easily log on
to
clubhouse or instagram and find
literally
lessons on how to purchase a home but
done
in with savvy and finesse
today we're gonna make a greenhouse i am
diying the entire closet
heather having bought her fixer-upper
sight unseen also looked to internet
personalities to help figure out how to
modernize
and to make sure her home was also an
investment
it gave us a lot of confidence they make
it look super easy
how we could do all of those things
ourselves my husband just installed a
laundry shoe which is something we never
would have thought of if
we didn't see an influence or do that
and and how
how easy it actually is really simple
do-it-yourself project you can do that
if you have any questions go ahead and
message me and in the case of neville
house
josh and pele hope that buyers see these
homes as potential secondary
income these young families look at
these products or look at our homes and
say
here's a turnkey airbnb this can serve
our family but this can also be the
perfect rental
we've tried to strike a balance in the
design of the home
for you know working well as a family
home that's going to be lived in and
also working as
a as an investment a lot of this just
points to
how millennials can utilize
and leverage social media to their
benefit
but it also speaks to again this moment
that folks want freedom so millennials
are really stepping up to this real
estate
game and taking ownership and building
well
of course not everything is as it seems
online
while social media can be a useful tool
for learning there's still a lot it
can't tell you about the home buying
experience
or living in the suburbs for that matter
we knew going into it
budgeting for a lot of renovations we
kind of thought
if we buy it at 450 we could put
two 300 000 into the house and really
make it
ours and our own i can't wait to replace
in this kitchen
and update our built-in deep fryer
which was not in the listing photos
we kind of got into the house and we
realized
that budget was completely unrealistic
we have a lot of people who see our
design on instagram
they say i love it can you come build
this on my property and then they'll
send us the lot which they bought
sight unseen during covet and because of
sight
conditions or zoning it's virtually
unbuildable
i think we all know that what you see on
instagram and what you see in real life
are two very different things so
while we can definitely as brokers
create these fantastic narratives
the one recommendation that i would give
is
do your homework don't believe
everything you say that's not to say
that you know there's dishonesty or
anything where people are trying to
manipulate you but
not everything you see is accurate
this shift towards social media house
hunting may also help to bring
equilibrium
to a market that has historically
disadvantaged specific groups of buyers
many of the traditional ways that
people get mortgages or or loans
often precluded black people because
they
they deemed us too risky for those loans
with technology there's ways to get
around that as long as
more black people get educated on racism
and discrimination and lending we're
going to figure out ways to get
around that racism
you